all right uh good afternoon everyone um
i usually say welcome to the jackson
institute for global affairs we're
across the street from horchow hall at
the moment here at the watson center
i'm ted whittenstein i'm executive
director of international security
studies at yale and we're just delighted
to partner with the wusai institute at
yale to co-host this discussion on the
alignment problem machine learning and
human values that's the title of brian
christian's wonderful new book we'll
introduce him in just a moment along
with professor
john lafferty who's going to moderate
this session so just silence all of your
devices
it's a thrill to even remind people to
do that in person again
this is not a hybrid zoom audience but
we are recording the session and we'll
make the video available after the fact
to the benefit of everyone uh thanks so
much to john lafferty
for inviting brian to campus and helping
us moderate this session as many of you
may know at the jackson institute we've
launched a new schmidt program on
artificial intelligence emerging
technologies and we're really building
bridges across the campus in computer
science and data science
across the university and of course
professor lafferty has extraordinary
expertise in this area himself
he's the john c malone professor of
statistics and data science he has a
secondary appointment in computer
science and he's director of the wusa
institute's center for neuro computation
and machine intelligence so thank you so
much professor laffney thank you brian
i'll let
john introduce
and kick off the conversation brian has
a presentation and then we'll make this
interactive with everyone so thank you
so much
thank you ted
all right so it's a um
it's a real pleasure and an honor for me
to introduce brian christian to you
brian is a science writer and he was
recently a science communicator in
residence at the simons institute for
the theory of computing
at berkeley
we're pleased to have him here with us
at yale today to speak on his recent
book um the alignment problem machine
learning
and human values
this is really a remarkable book that
dives into the history and the future of
of machine learning and ai focusing on
the emerging
societal and ethical issues
that we are rapidly being confronted
with whether we're ready or not
and as the world tries to get its uh
collective head around um the
implications of the advances in a.i
um brian christian's writing is is
helping to
clarify the the issues
now as those of you who have read any of
uh of his books will know
brian has a superpower
which is a remarkable ability to distill
extremely complex technical concepts in
a way that gives the reader a glimpse
of the core ideas in this case the the
ideas behind different machine learning
and ai frameworks
to understand both their power
and their limitations
the alignment problem is a book about
machine learning but that of course
um also involves a lot of discussion
about human learning and human abilities
and in in biases
brian is also the author of the most
human human
which looks at ai through the lens of
the turing test
and also algorithms to live by
which was co-written with the cognitive
and computer scientist tom griffiths
so we're very fortunate that brian is
here to give us a presentation on on
this book and afterwards we'll have some
discussion
and we'll welcome questions and
engagement from all of you so welcome to
yale brian it's a pleasure to have you
here
thank you so much ted and thank you john
it's it means a lot to be here
so i want to talk this afternoon about
the alignment problem in machine
learning
namely how to make sure that machine
learning systems systems that learn by
example rather than being explicitly
programmed
actually do
what we want and what we hope
we find ourselves i think at a very
crucial juncture uh around the
development and deployment of machine
learning systems in the real world and i
think that critically there are
questions here not only of technology
but also of governance and law and
policy in what the path forward looks
like
so
what do i mean when i say
a transformative decade that we're
coming out of well many of you in the
room will be familiar but just so that
we're on the same page
we've seen in the area area of image
classification
my slides are kind of flickering in and
out so
we may have a
slightly more verbal than visual
presentation
in the area of image classification
where you're trying to determine the
contents of an image
we've seen
error rates drop 42 percent in a single
year in 2012 and cumulatively by more
than 92 percent over six years
um
and that just doesn't happen uh very
often
uh now fast forward to the present
and it is now possible to train a system
uh to achieve uh human
comparable accuracy on the imagenet
competition uh for 4.59
um so in the span of
nine years this task went from
impossible to you can do it for four
dollars and fifty cents
um
in fact
uh
today you can't even take
a camera a picture with a contemporary
smartphone camera like an iphone or an
android uh without invoking in this case
an 11 stage machine learning pipeline
that is doing everything from uh the
auto exposure to the focal distance to
the white balance to the color
correction denoising it's fusing
multiple exposures together
all of this is happening silently and
invisibly in real time
and
it imposes some like interesting
constraints on the types of photos that
you can and cannot take so for example
my friend reports to me that it's very
hard to take a photograph of falling
snow at night
because the iphone software thinks of it
as noise on the sensor and denoises the
snow out of your photograph and you have
the photograph with no snow falling
um but i think this is a really
interesting analogy for the relationship
that we've come to have with machine
learning namely
that ways
ways that are ubiquitous but in at the
same time invisible it has kind of
interposed itself uh between ourselves
and the world it is mediating our
experience of the world in ways that we
don't always appreciate
of course this is far from the most
consequential use of machine learning uh
we are seeing autonomous cars
increasingly on neighborhood streets
certainly where i live in san francisco
it is almost
every hour of the day there are cars
from crews waymo etc coming through and
you always have this awkward interaction
at an intersection where you're not
quite sure if it sees that you're there
or if it's going to yield to you um or
whether it's going to be more or less
aggressive than a human driver would be
in that situation
and
andre carpathi who runs ai at tesla has
described machine learning software
as like a kind of fungus that is eating
away at the c-plus plus code that he and
his team have so painfully written over
the years
and i mentioned this partly because
we have this narrative that machine
learning is replacing human expertise
and human judgment but i think it's
actually even more significant than that
it's also replacing traditional software
engineering practices
and then
you might might or may not be able to
see it on the screen but there was a
tweet from waymo ceo
uh
yesterday saying that they have just now
begun officially doing uh
driverless cars with no human in the
driver's seat
in san francisco so i am the human
guinea pig for this particular exercise
um
so
not only in kind of
celebrated high-tech examples like this
but in ways that i think are
in many ways going under the radar
machine learning systems
some of them uh
no more complex than what you could put
in an excel spreadsheet are increasingly
penetrating the decision-making of our
institutions
public and private so
if you look just at the criminal justice
system there has been an exponential
uptick in the use of statistical and
machine learning risk assessments
in the u.s criminal justice system
and so machine learning is replacing
both human expertise and traditional
software
it's doing it in ways that shape our
most everyday interactions and could
also determine the course of our lives
i would argue that there's a sense in
which we are we are putting the world
literally and figuratively on autopilot
um and so there are a lot of reasons i
think to be frankly concerned are these
systems actually learning what we think
they're learning
and can we actually trust them to do
what we think they're going to do
now
this is far from a new concern in fact
it goes all the way back to 1960 when
the mit cybernetics pioneer norbert
weiner wrote this i think very prescient
essay called
some
moral and technical consequences of
automation
and weiner used the metaphor of the
sorcerer's apprentice
which many of us know as this lovable
mickey mouse cartoon where mickey
enchants this broom
uh animates this inanimate object and
gives it some simple command like fetch
water from the cauldron of course mickey
is not quite precise enough in how he
formulates his command
and anyone who's watched the cartoon
knows that he ends up almost drowning
himself by the time that the master
magician appears
and weiner says i think quite
prophetically
this is not the stuff of fairy tales
this is what's coming for us in the
relationship that we're going to have
with artificial intelligence
the famous quote of his is if we use to
achieve our purposes a mechanical agency
with whose operation we cannot interfere
once we have set it going then we had
better be quite sure that the purpose we
put into the machine is the thing that
we truly desire
uh today this has become one of the
central uh concerns of the field of ai
and we know it as the alignment problem
so five years ago five and a half years
ago i decided i wanted to tell the story
of the alignment problem
of the history of machine learning
how it's intersecting in deep ways with
human norms and human values
and the technical and interdisciplinary
community that is coming together around
some of those questions to do what i
think is some of the most exciting but
also important work in the field that
process ended up taking me through
archival research into the fields
pioneers people like walter pitts and
warren mcculloch
all the way to about 100 oral histories
and interviews that comprise the the
stories of the book
obviously we don't have time to get into
much
uh of that level of detail but there's a
few threads that i'd like to pull
through this morning
so
said most plainly
how can a machine learning system as
weiner said fail to have uh the purpose
put into it that we truly desire
and what in turn can we do about it
and because this is co-sponsored by the
wusai institute for the study of human
cognition i'll try to highlight as well
a few of what i think are some of the
juiciest
intersections between machine learning
and human cognition along the way
okay let's begin so
broadly we can think of a machine
learning system as having two halves
there is the training data the set of
examples uh from which the
system learns and what's called the
objective function which is how we're
going to mathematically define success
in each of those examples
each of those offers an opportunity for
things
to become misaligned and we'll look at
each of those in turn i'll start first
with the training data and i'll be a
little bit briefer here so there's more
time to talk about
the objective function
so many of this in this room i suspect
will be familiar with one of the most
infamous cases of machine learning in
particular
image classification gone wrong
which was in the summer of 2015 google
photos
suggested the auto-generated caption
gorillas
to an album of selfies taken by web
developer jackie alcine
and his friend
this incident and others like it led to
a kind of reckoning
into the work of people like mit's joy
bonwini who did a i think now classic
intersectional analysis on commercial
face recognition face uh detection
systems of 2017 and 2018
showing that the error rates uh in then
state-of-the-art you know commercial
systems were orders of magnitude higher
for darker skinned females in particular
something like 30 times higher
than they were
for white males
and this has come as part of a more
broad
scrutiny of the kinds of data sets that
get used both in industry and in
academia
one of the most used and most cited data
sets of the 2010s for example
is called labeled faces in the wild
which was
scraped together
on the web using digital newspapers
newspaper front pages from the 2000s
an analysis that was done
just several years ago showed for the
first time that as a result of this
methodology the data set contains twice
as many pictures of george w bush
as it does of all black women combined
so anyone working with this data set to
build face recognition technology uh had
perhaps inadvertently built uh george w
bush recognition technology
um these very same sorts of data set
issues
are also being seen in autonomous
driving including in the 2018 crash of
the uber car that killed a pedestrian
in tempe arizona
if you read the national transportation
safety board report
you find something really striking which
was that the system basically did not
have any training data of jaywalkers
and so it was just fundamentally
unprepared to encounter someone crossing
a road not at a crosswalk
what's more the system was built on this
object classification system that had a
very rigid set of categories that
included pedestrians cyclist
debris etc
and had thousands of examples of each of
those things but this particular woman
was walking a bicycle
across the street which was something
that the system had never seen
and so all bets essentially were off
to underscore this point this is head of
ai
at tesla andre
speaking
at my
institution uc berkeley and explaining
that when he was a phd student he lost
95 percent of his sleep thinking about
models and algorithms and today running
ai at tesla he loses 75 percent of his
sleep thinking about data sets
we're starting to see some norms emerge
not unlike the nutrition facts that you
see on food packaging
to indicate the contents and potential
dangers of data sets so this is from
google uh microsoft ibm etc have their
own versions of these they're called
model cards or data cards um and they
include information about the provenance
of the data and possible misuse possible
bias etc
and labeled faces in the wild itself now
starting in 2019
comes with this big red warning label
attached telling you about the various
skus in the data set
these sorts of disclosures i don't think
will prevent all harms and neither do
nutrition facts for that matter
but it's a start and i'm encouraged to
see that norm emerging
although i suspect andre carpathi will
have to keep losing sleep for for the
foreseeable future
so we'll come back a little bit to
questions of training data at the end
when we talk about language models but
for now let's shift the focus to the
objective function
this is how we're going to numerically
operationalize success in each of these
examples
we have seen this be
the crux of many alignment issues in ai
i think perhaps most well-known is the
compass system that does a pre-trial
risk assessment in many jurisdictions
the u.s
and really the
the focus of the pro publica
investigation into the system in 2016
which caused a number of headlines
uh ended up sharpening into a question
of
the correct statistical definition of
fairness to be used in the case of
classifiers like this
so one potential uh way of defining
fairness is what's called calibration
where you say okay if someone is an 8
out of 10 risk to be rearrested then
they're going to have the same
probability of being rearrested whether
they're white or black et cetera
and this seems pretty intuitive and it
seems pretty desirable
but there are other definitions of
fairness that we could use for example
what's called equalized odds or
equalized opportunity which looks more
at the error rates and the composition
of false positives to false negatives
etc and it looks for this property to be
the same across different groups
and that also seems like something that
we would really want and seems intuitive
in an aspect of our
yeah our legal intuitions about what
fairness might actually mean
um it turns out we don't have time to
get into this but a system can't satisfy
these definitions at the same time
and so we are left with i think a really
interesting set of questions at the
intersection of computer science and
public policy around how we want to
statistically operationalize these
ideals
of fairness and equal treatment that
exist in the law
you could think about
even the infamous google photos gorillas
example that we began with as a matter
not only of training data gone wrong but
also of an objective function gone wrong
so the classic objective function that's
used in image classification is what's
called cross entropy loss but you can
simply think of it as wanting to
minimize the number of
misclassifications
well what could go wrong that seems
quite intuitive indeed
if all you care about is minimizing the
number of misclassifications then you're
implicitly assuming that any
misclassification of any x as any y is
equally harmful
but i think part of what the google the
google photos example shows us is that
this is not true at all
there are many many errors made by
google photos that didn't result in you
know a national scandal um and you know
personal apologies from from the
engineers uh in fact i think it's
probably likely that certain
misclassifications are millions of times
more harmful than others and so how do
we try to
reorganize you know some of the
fundamental objective functions of
something like image classification
there are a number of computer
scientists including stuart russell who
have argued that we should make this
loss matrix itself something that we
want the system to learn um we'll come
back to that idea at the very end
thus far we've been talking about what's
called supervised learning as many of
you probably familiar
in discussing the objective function i'd
like to now turn our attention to a
different branch of machine learning
which is called reinforcement learning
so if supervised learning is about
predicting certain hidden attributes
from visible attributes reinforcement
learning is about
essentially maximizing rewards and
minimizing punishments through a series
of behaviors
now this has been used in many
arenas within machine learning and some
of the
i think most significant successes like
uh playing atari games with superhuman
capacity defeating the world champion at
go uh increasing dexterity of uh robots
and so forth
are examples of reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is also i think
to an underappreciated extent being used
in consumer tech so this is a very
interesting paper that facebook
published a few years ago talking about
the use of reinforcement learning for
delivering notifications to users so
they had previously used a supervised
learning system that simply ranked all
the possible notifications by the
probability that you would interact with
them
and then if it was over a certain
probability they would send you the
notification and this led to various
things including people getting burned
out and turning notifications off which
they didn't like
and so they changed to a reinforcement
learning system where facebook gets
points for the interactions that you
do with their notifications but once you
turn notifications off it's like game
over in the in the atari context and in
fact they literally use the exact same
model architecture dqn
that deepmind used to play atari games
facebook is now using this to play us
right so i think to we're all familiar
with the expression you know you're not
the consumer you're the product but i
think we can maybe add another adage
which is like
when we think about the gamification of
social media
we are not the player we are literally
the game as far as facebook is concerned
we we are substituting for the atari in
this context
um i also just want to mention very
briefly in passing that reinforcement
learning is of particular interest to me
because of its rich connections to
neuroscience
in fact a particular set of
ideas in the
early 90s called temporal difference
learning
whose first major success was in the use
of
computer backgammon
ended up by the end of the 1990s
becoming accepted as the
explanation for what was going on in the
human dopamine system
which had been an unsolved riddle in the
neuroscience community i think this is
one of the most interesting stories uh
in reinforcement learning and it shows
that i think there's a very deep
resonance indeed between some of these
ideas in computer science
and the same fundamental algorithms of
learning that evolution found
but what i want to focus on
is
uh this mysterious numerical reward at
the heart of reinforcement learning uh
these points that the system is trying
to maximize because that reward function
is what determines the behavior
and it turns out to be exceedingly
difficult to develop a reward function
that doesn't break down in some
sometimes hilarious sometimes tragic way
my favorite example comes from david
andre and astroteller who work at google
x now but in their grad student days
they were working on a robotic soccer
competition
and their robotic soccer robots were
just wandering all around the field at
random they had no idea how to score
goals
and so they decided to give them a tiny
numerical incentive which
in computer science is called reward
shaping but you can just think of it as
an incentive
of something like 1 100th of a goal for
taking possession of the ball
what did the system learn to do
it learned to approach the ball
carefully and then vibrate its paddle as
quickly as possible taking possession
you know like 50 times a second
so if you talk to any reinforcement
learning researcher they have their own
set of kind of horror stories like this
of the system
doing what they said but not what they
wanted
and this is something too that i think
has very deep connections to human
psychology and human incentive design
my favorite example here comes from my
friend and collaborator tom griffiths
who's a cognitive scientist at princeton
he's also a dad
and one day his five-year-old daughter
was sweeping up some crumbs on the floor
and put them in the trash can and he was
very proud of this and so he he did what
any parent would do and activated his
reward function which is called praise
and said wow great job honey you did
such a good job sweeping and he watched
as his daughter you know beaming with
pride then took the trash can and dumped
it out on the floor in order to start
sweeping even more and get an even
greater helping of praise
and so tom had fallen prey to exactly
the same kind of incentive failure um
that uh david andre and astroteller had
i think it's quite interesting
that um
cognitive scientists and
economists are turning to the computer
science community for ideas about how to
um create incentive structures that
don't distort behavior
um but the moral for our purposes and
thinking about alignment is simply that
it's very hard to create an incentive
system uh that doesn't break down and
can't be exploited in some way
uh we see this even in toy environments
like
atari games
in the simplest of atari games it might
be possible to simply reward our system
for getting points in the game
uh space invaders is one example
but even by the time we get to super
mario world
points don't really reflect the actual
playing of the game like you can get
points for getting coins and breaking
bricks but that's not the point of the
game the point of the game is to save
the princess
and
if you look at for example this boat
racing game which is called coast
runners there's a famous example from
open ai they train the system to
maximize points in the boat racing game
but it found a loophole where you can do
donuts in this little harbor that has
these self-replenishing power-ups and it
forgets about the race altogether and
just drives off the course to do these
donuts infinitely
in games that are very stingy with
points for example this one called
montezuma's revenge uh then a system
based only on random exploration and
then uh using reinforcement learning to
get more and more points uh we'll never
figure out how to get the
points at all and will just sort of give
up and stand there uh
and not move at all
i think this is very telling so even in
these really toy sandbox domains it's
very very difficult to articulate a
reward function that incentivizes what
we actually want the system to do so
what hope do we have in any kind of real
world setting like driving a car through
the street
of making this work
the conclusion i think by most
most people who think about ai safety
is that generally speaking it is simply
not safe to manually supply a reward
function to an rl system particularly in
the real world there's always going to
be some weird loophole or something it's
going to exploit
but maybe we can do something else
maybe we can make the learning of the
reward function part of the machine
learning problem itself
maybe we can
have the system learn
the reward in our heads from us
and my favorite example of this is a
paper that was a collaboration between
deep mind and open ai
paul christiano
led the deepmind effort and jan laika
excuse me the other way around
and they wanted to take something
that would be very obvious
if the system got it right but almost
impossible to specify
numerically and what they settled on was
backflips so they wanted to see if they
could get a robot to do a backflip now
if you think about this it's very hard
to come up with some mathematical
formula that determines like what a
backflip is as a function of you know
the rotation or the torques or whatever
um it'd be very hard to even do a
demonstration like with your body and be
hard to do demonstration with a joystick
but you'd know it if you saw it so the
question was was that enough
so they had this really wonderful setup
where they would have this robot just
wiggling around at random and they'd
show you two video clips and you'd get
this instruction that says look at the
clips and select the one in which better
things happen
i just love how vague that is so which
one of these wrigglings looks
infinitesimally more like a backflip
um
and in so doing the system would then
behind the scenes build this reward
model of what what reward it thought you
had in your head that would explain
these preferential judgments that you'd
made and then it would go and try to
optimize for that and show you two more
video clips
again and again you pick you know the
left clip the right clip blah blah you
do this for about an hour which is
fairly boring but by the end of the hour
something amazing has happened which is
that the system is doing these like
gymnastically perfect backflips
um i guess you don't quite have the
refresh rate to appreciate the aesthetic
beauty but um
it is tucking its itself in in order to
spin faster like the same way a figure
skater tucks their arms in
it's sticking the landing
um and
i find even more intriguing every person
that they did this with the system ended
up with a backflip that was slightly
different as if like each of us has our
own platonic ideal of a backflip in our
heads
um and i think this is really remarkable
um that we have
a mechanism
for extracting these
aesthetic preferences out of human
brains using nothing but these binary
preference judgments
um and i think that is really uh
for me sort of a beacon of hope um that
we can get beyond the sort of manual
specification of reward
um
now
i thought i might
say a few words about large language
models which is kind of the current
frontier of ai alignment i'll try to be
pretty quick because i want to make sure
that we have plenty of time to chat
um
so you can think of
what to me is sort of the current
frontier in machine learning which is
these so-called large language models
uh
for people who aren't familiar it's
basically
autocorrect on steroids
so we have these systems on our phones
that will predict the next word that
we're going to type and in fact they
will secretly dynamically change the
like input buttons on our keyboard um in
invisibly to make more typical letters
like literally wider on the screen and
easier to hit
um but what would it mean to have an
autocomplete system that could auto
complete like an entire term paper
so that is what the current generation
of things for people who aren't familiar
i think it's really stunning so here are
a few examples of
me playing with open ai's gpt so i said
the following is an essay for mrs
simpson's fourth grade class about what
would happen if dogs could talk and it
produces like i think a reasonable
fourth grade essay about what dogs would
say
i could say this is my ap english exam
about
symbolism in the works of hermann
melville and out comes i think a very
reasonable like high school level essay
about symbolism and moby dick
um i even
asked it to give me my own remarks to
you
uh you know on the alignment problem
and it came up with something
fairly generic but i think totally
coherent
and why stop at pros why not do code as
well so
microsoft
has this thing called github copilot
which will auto-complete your code for
you you can say the following is a
python function that will blah blah blah
and out comes python
deepmind has the same thing
but
there is a fundamental alignment problem
here
between the auto-complete objective and
these systems actually being helpful to
us
so for example if you say explain the
moon landing to a six-year-old
you think you're giving a command to the
system but the system merely thinks it
is auto-completing a document that
contains that sentence and so it
auto-completes it as here's a list of
commands explain blah explain blah
explain blah well that's not what we
actually wanted
right so there's a fundamental
difference in the objective that we've
trained the system on and what we how we
actually want to use it
there's also this fundamental problem as
many of you know which is that the
internet is quite toxic
and so if you build a language model on
the internet it will sometimes say
extremely toxic things
uh in fact this is a problem that
actually gets worse not better as the
size of the model goes up
and so
particularly if there's any hint of
toxicity in your own writing or your own
prompt
the smarter the more powerful the model
is uh the more likely it's going to pick
up on that and make an even more toxic
auto-completion and the same thing is
true of buggy code
so there's a lot of buggy code on github
if you start writing buggy code
a powerful
language model will realize ah this
guy's writing bad code and in my
training data bad code tends to be
followed by even more bad code and so it
will take your mistake and use that as a
reason to give you a bunch of crappy
code
in autocomplete but that's not what you
wanted um so again this is the alignment
problem in in all of its glory
um and we've seen reward modeling
techniques like with the backflip uh
used here
where they will uh give the
human raters from mechanical turk a
bunch of possible
outputs from the model they will ask the
people to rank them from best to worst
and they will use this to generate
a reward model of what a good summary of
a document is and amazingly this appears
to generalize
um
up to a point
of course there's an interesting
question of who are these raiders do
their preferences coincide with what our
preferences would be whose definition of
toxicity or you know do we care about
etc etc uh in some ways i think these
are some of the oldest ethical questions
of them all which is just who gets a
seat at the table
um
as a as a place to sum up
i think this is significant
this reward modeling technique is
significant not only within ai itself
but also for broader forms of
institutional decision making if you
think about the way companies
governments etc make decisions often
they determine some explicit metric
there's some meeting at which a metric
is determined and then that metric is
optimized until there's some future
meeting where they decide to change
their mind
so for example at tinder there was a
meeting in like 2013 or something where
they decided that their metric was going
to be maximized swipes per week and so
any change to their layout or their ui
et cetera was going to be a b tested and
it would only be rolled out if it
increased the average number of swipes
per week and so if anyone has heard
people complaining like uh all i'm doing
is just swiping mindlessly but there's
no like actual interaction well like
that's what their you know that's their
objective function that's what they're
optimizing for
um
we saw facebook which was optimizing for
many years for time on site and then
this produced sort of addictiveness
uh they scrapped that then they started
optimizing for engagement and this
produced the outrage machine that we now
know so well
um but you see this in in outside of
tech two you know there's this desire to
make more kind of evidence-based
objective assessment in education
but this results in teaching to the test
we can optimize for shareholder returns
or gdp and this ends up with huge
externalities to the environment to
inequality etc etc
so if 30 minutes of case studies on
machine learning gone wrong has imparted
anything it's that it's a this is a
highly dubious way of running
a tech startup let alone the world right
is to just define some objective metric
and just hit the gas pedal
but maybe reward modeling suggests that
there's something there's some
alternative here
so people often ask me if i'm
pessimistic or optimistic about ai
if i'm pessimistic it's because the
alignment problem is in my view exactly
the way that human civilization is
already going off the rails and the ai
is just a force multiplier of that or
our ability to ride bad metrics uh into
the externalities of no return
um however um if i'm optimistic it's
because i think
we are coming to an understanding that
there's something beyond the
optimization of metrics so we're
starting to see social media ui
removing the quantitative part of the
experience
as if to say like don't optimize too
hard for the number of people that like
each photo
um
and i think most poignantly we have this
idea
that you can just present to people two
different worlds right two different
versions of uh the timeline or something
as as generic as that and just say
select the one in which better things
happen which of these experiences do you
prefer you don't have to be able to even
articulate
why you prefer one to another and you
can still allow the system to have a
more
nuanced
representation
than you would get by just defining
metrics yourself
okay so this is roughly speaking the
current state of the alignment problem i
think there's a lot of work to do i hope
that's clear and i honestly think this
is some of the most exciting uh work
that's happening right now both in on
the policy side and in the technical
side i think this is likely to be in my
view the defining human project of the
2020s is how to get machine learning to
work for us um if not the 21st century
so
at its best i think it offers us a a
revelatory encounter with our own
uh
human nature what we value how we learn
what we want
um
on that note i'll give the last word to
ellen turing so he was giving a radio
address in 1952
about really early experiments in
machine learning that he was doing
and he says to his co-panelists you know
i've i've been doing a bunch of these
experiments lately but the system takes
an awful lot of intervention it's always
learning the wrong thing or not learning
the right thing and i'm constantly
having to jump in and correct course
and his co-panelist says okay but who is
learning turing you or the machine and
he says well
i guess we both were
thanks
okay thank you brian that's so
interesting um
so maybe i can start with a few
questions and then we can open it up for
for more discussion
but um
you know maybe i can start with um
your last quote from turing is is a good
place to start and one of the things i
wanted to ask about
which is um you know co-evolution of of
humans and machines
so you know so machine learning has
advanced um some people like to joke by
stochastic graduate student descent
and um
and that's one type of uh you know
survival of the fittest algorithms
evolution that has uh advanced the
technology for many years
but as these systems have become fielded
and used by people there's this
co-evolution where
as we use them um they're they're they
become adapted to us and then we become
adapted to them is is that turing quote
hints at
and um
and you know without becoming you know
we could become grandiose about it and
sort of uh draw an analogy between the
agricultural and the industrial
revolutions that the ai revolution is
leading us into now
but what are your thoughts on how
you know machines and and human
societies are going to co-evolve in this
way
yeah
i think that's a great
that's a great
line of inquiry there's
a quote that comes to my mind from
hannah arendt where she's talking
in the mid 20th century about
behaviorism and she says my problem with
behaviorism is not that it's false but
that it could become true
and i think about that quote a lot in
the context of ai i think it is true
in almost any
computer system whether it's sort of
traditional object-oriented programming
where you have to design this like mini
world with nouns and verbs um or
something like machine learning where
you're determining like a category
structure etc
um
these are simplifications you know we
use the the word model there's the
famous quote for george box all models
are false but some are
useful
um
and i think there's a there's a danger
that
the models that we're building become so
powerful
that they reshape the reality that that
they were originally approximating and
then the reality itself conforms to the
assumptions that were made in the model
so for example
um
if
every car on the road ran the uber
software from 2018 and killed jaywalkers
then people would stop jaywalking or the
people who did jaywalk would be killed
and so the assumption that the model
makes of there are no jaywalkers would
become true
um you sometimes see this um there can
be kind of a confirmation bias even in
auto complete systems where
uh i for for many years
uh my phone would auto correct the word
ill to capital i apostrophe ll even if
in a syntax of like yeah i'm still
feeling a little bit
ill it would replace it with isle i
don't know if 2022 is the year we
finally stopped doing that but um
my response to that
is like to fight it the first couple
times and then to just cave and be like
okay you want me to say sick i'm sick
um
and that's something that like really
gets under my skin as a creative writer
which is that it has always been
the
uh the role the calling of poets of
painters etc to
um
find authentic idiosyncratic modes of
expression to sort of buck the
traditions and the conventions
um and that's hard enough
if you're just living in a society that
has certain norms you know but
picasso wasn't painting on a canvas that
was literally pushing his brush strokes
into more conventional shapes you know
under him and that's essentially what we
have the textual equivalent now and
that's another way in which these models
are false but be could become true
that a team deploy you know a team at
apple or whatever deploys this model
and they see like oh our accuracy keeps
going up and up we're getting better and
better at predicting the word that the
person wanted to type well maybe that's
true or maybe the person's just giving
in
um and so you're impoverishing the
language
uh so that is a kind of co-evolution
there's a oxford philosopher named john
lucas who says if and when we pass the
turing test it will not be because
machines have become so intelligent but
because human speech has become so
wooden
um so that's the kind of thing that
worries me from a co-evolution
standpoint yeah really interesting
and another question goes to the first
part of your talk when you talk about
the data
problem um you know i guess this is the
one that's now keeping andre carpathi
awake at night at night yeah um
you know another way of talking about
this is you know garbage and garbage out
yeah and you can you can see this
very easily in word embeddings i think
you talk about this in your book
um and and you can see it in the large
language models as well and that's why
you know open ai pulled the plug
on the on on the uh access to those
language models initially
and so that but the question i want to
ask about this is that one way of
thinking about the the issue here is
that
um we're training these systems on human
data but we're holding the the the
systems to a higher standard yeah than
we hold humans to and i think rightly so
yeah
and and so first in a domain like
self-driving cars it's you know it's
it's easy to say you know that you know
we want the statistical rate of
accidents to be you know much
lower than it would be for humans
but in other domains like you know
language um it's not so clear and if we
can't even
agree on uh fundamental you know
questions of uh you know morality
amongst ourselves how can we prescribe
them for machines
so what is your thinking on this you
know notion of holding the machines to a
higher standard yeah
i think there's two things there
the first part is is this idea of how
can you
how can you do better than human
morality there was a quote uh from a
google researcher saying you know this
idea that we need
machine systems to embody human values
is not good enough because human values
are not good enough as they are today um
and you it's interesting because you
would see this in like the 80s 90s 2000s
in the game playing literature because
back then
a lot of the methodology for even like
the way deep blue played chess was we're
going to start with a huge database of
grandmaster games and learn to predict
the way that the grand master plays and
then we'll play like that
and you started to see even even in
computer checkers people are writing
like
yeah but
our program is going to get to a certain
point where it's actually better than a
human
but it because it's going to play a
different move than the one that human
played in that situation we're going to
tag that as like an error
and so how can we ever hope to transcend
that that barrier and essentially you
know the way that you do it
is by
you know just having the program play
itself from scratch and this is like
alpha zero and so forth and you can sort
of throw the human data away either
later or just from the very beginning
never use it
so is there a way to do something like
that in the moral domain which sounds
crazy
but i think there's a number of people
who are asking that question seriously
um one of the people who comes to my
mind is paul cristiano
he was at open ai he now runs his own
thing called the alignment research
center
he has this idea which is called humans
consulting
hch which is a recursive acronym
and the idea is that
you ask people some question
and you give them a computer system as
like a resource like as a research
assistant
you know it could be like is such and
such medical procedure ethical or not
and that your computer assistant
is like
empowering you to be better informed
about that than you would otherwise be
but it's also
trying to predict your ultimate decision
and as it becomes better able to predict
your decision it's better able to inform
you or you know empower you and
in theory you can get a sort of
bootstrapping effect or sort of a
virtuous circle where it can then
essentially push you
deeper into your own
values than you would have gotten on
your own but without supplying anything
else from the outside i think that's a
really tantalizing idea
i've yet to see anyone really take a
crack at it as a you know research
project but i think that's really
interesting the other aspect of of what
i think
is going on here is this question of how
can machines embody human values when
human values are heterogeneous
people don't always agree
so in the open ai research the language
research i talked about at the very end
agreement between their mechanical
turkers on like which summary is a
better summary is about 73 percent so
that's good enough that we can just kind
of go with the modal answer
um
but what do you do when people don't
agree or where they're sort of
multimodal preferences uh you see this
with self-driving cars where it's like
if half of the people would swerve
around the object to the left and half
swerve to the right you don't want to
just split the difference and plow into
it
and so um work on how to deal with like
heterogeneous preferences i mean you see
even
even something seemingly banal as like a
recommended recommendation system like
for parents who have children that use
their spotify account
their spotify is like forever polluted
with these like dumb children songs and
they can never like
get back to the music that they like and
so even multimodal preferences for
something as seemingly everyday in banal
as like music we still haven't figured
that out and it's sort of an open
research problem yeah and then replace
you know parents and children with you
know
one human society one country and
another and yeah these problems are
magnified so i want to open it up to
questions um but before i do one
question
that um
i think a lot of people would like to
ask you which is that
you know i think you really have a
remarkable remarkable ability to distill
you know very
complex ideas in in machine learning and
communicate them very effectively
and what would you say to you know
somebody in you know who who wants to
um you know learn about machine learning
in in in but is not in a stem field you
know maybe they're seeking to be to
serve in a leadership role
um and to communicate some of these
ideas in a way that is both substantial
and you know impactful
yeah
i think that's a great question you know
one of the things that i've been
thinking about is
during the writing of the book
a law was passed in san francisco my
city
uh
mandating the use of this thing called
the arnold tool which is a you know
statistical risk assessment instrument
um
in city courts
um
and i went with the person who's now the
d.a in san francisco and sat in on
arraignment hearings for a day it was
like maybe a week or two after that law
went into effect it was very interesting
hearing these judges you know get this
readout of this statistical
system
and say
okay your trial date is four weeks from
now i have to decide whether you stay in
jail or go home in the next four weeks
this thing says you're like an eight out
of ten that sounds kind of bad so i
guess you're gonna go to jail
um i'm exaggerating slightly but that
was that was the kind of thing that one
heard
and
i've thought a lot about how for many
people in non technical fields you know
you could be judged sitting on the bench
for 20 30 years suddenly there's a law
that's passed that says now you have to
work arm in arm with this machine
learning system
you don't really know
you don't have a working knowledge of
like
uh
any of these bias issues or what might
make someone you know an exception to
the rule or even really what the risk is
that the risk assessment is predicting
um there are many cases where the risk
assessment explicitly says like this is
not for sentencing but people still use
it for sentencing
i think there's a great need for that
that's part of my motivation in writing
the book honestly was feeling that there
was a broad community of
non-computer scientists whether that's
policy people doctors
lawyers etc that i could try to serve by
offering
a little bit of a
gentle machine learning 101 curriculum
you know full of personal narratives and
um hopefully readable enough that it
would be uh
you know useful so that that's
that's something i've thought a lot
about i've also
um
a couple weeks ago i did an event with
the ai subcommittee of the uk parliament
and they asked me this question of like
all of the parliamentarians want to know
more about ai like what do we do
and
i recommended you know maybe there
should be some kind of
consulting group or center of knowledge
within the government that can then get
loaned out
you know as needed to advise or work
with people as these sorts of things
come up
i wouldn't mind seeing something like
that in the us
i think it's very much an open question
though how to because i do i do feel
that
fluency with some of these basic ideas
in machine learning is becoming just uh
part of the core curriculum of being a
citizen you know being being a person i
mean
um even knowing
in a self-driving car when to be more
vigilant
and when to be more relaxed you know one
of the interviews that i did in the book
was with dean pomerleau who was
did one of the first
rides in a self-driving car in the early
90s
with a computer that was like one tenth
as powerful as a first generation apple
watch
he still drove on the highway for two
hours and i asked him what the
experience was like and he said well i
knew that if i encountered like if i
went through a tunnel i was gonna have
to like hover my hands over the wheel
because i knew that this was like out of
the distribution of normal sunlit
you know road markings
and so that's the kind of thing where
now like every tesla owner
should have that same kind of spidey
sense of like oh there's a weird thing
happening where there's like a full moon
but there's a forest fire so it looks
like a yellow light hanging in mid-air
like i'm gonna just
you know pay a little bit more attention
now than i normally would i do think
that's just kind of part of being a
person now so
i don't know exactly what is the best
way to address that but
it's something that's very much on my
mind yeah gets at this issue of trust
that we talked about yeah absolutely oh
thank you um
so let's um
open up to questions
yeah
um
um
so
i found it very interesting but i was
i'm just not fully understanding the
optimistic note that you ended on sure
um and that's in particular so take
um
take the example you gave uh where
humans oh yeah so maybe this will help
with the mask um
okay
it's i'm not even sure it's on
um oh okay okay so can i pull it down to
okay so in that example what was key was
that the humans that did the better
thing knew what a backflip was it was
something they recognized since they
could make a judgment but the real issue
for us
is recognizing or for machines is
recognizing entirely new kinds of events
like a pandemic
or of a president that doesn't follow
the rule of law
um or something interesting called the
internet and there's radically new
technological um advances
and when something like that happens
um those rough judgments of this is
better than that like
in other words those new things first
um we're terrible at describing them
before they come and predict them
although humans are very good at like a
kind of one-shot learning so then they
can make judgments quite quickly
machines are not like that and moreover
these um better than judgments that we
might that the machine might be relying
on could i think
quite straightforwardly be invalidated
because everything changes or deep
things change in all kinds of unexpected
ways yeah that just seems to be that's
the pro and that's the real problem it's
not that using machines for things that
we already have have control over and no
it's about
trust
with entirely new categories of events
so i was just sort of deeply unclear on
i mean that seems like a nice thing but
that's not
the real alignment problem
i think there's fundamentally as you say
it is the nature of the world that you
know our world models are constantly
being invalidated and we're constantly
needing to revise our sense of how
things work or what the relevant
categorical distinctions even are and i
i think your point is well taken
the area that for me feels relevant to
what you're describing is the idea of
uncertainty like calibrated uncertainty
in a model so for example the uber
collision that i referenced
part of what was going on was that as i
said it didn't recognize what a
jaywalker was it had this very brittle
category distinction between pedestrian
and cyclist
and so if you read the like
essentially the black box output of what
the system was thinking like in the five
seconds before the crash it was like
oh that's a person no it's a cyclist
because i can see the frame of like no
they're definitely walking their feet
are on their no there's definitely a
handlebar in it and it's flickering
between these two categories and i think
that alone
should have been evidence that the
system didn't really know what it was
dealing with and its category structure
was inadequate sorry there's a
difference between uncertainty where
you're not sure if it's a b or c
and unknown okay which is a different
kind of uncertainty in probabilistic
literature and then you haven't got it's
not oh is it a is it b c it's some other
kind of thing that you can't classify
and that's the problem i'm trying to
target so i think it's different so i
mean there's work on this tom dietrich
at university of oregon has what he
calls open category learning so there's
this
this idea of how do we do object
classification when one of the
classifications is like i have no idea
um and so he did a project with the epa
on of all things identifying flies in a
stream
and it turns out that a lot of the stuff
that you catch in a net if you put it in
a stream is not any kind of fly at all
and so it ended up being that they
needed like a very robust like this
isn't any of those things
mechanism and so
that sort of work i think speaks to what
you're talking about obviously i think
we need to go further
i'm going to help m.c here
question
yep hold on i'm coming your way give me
one second
just uh
speak up
yeah sure
uh so thanks for coming i really enjoyed
this um
so i was interested in studying the
alignment problem i'm an undergrad i was
interested in learning about it and
researching it and uh i couldn't do that
at yale there was no one doing that at
yale so i had to go work for stuart
russell and jacob steinart i had to go
to berkeley in other words and you know
i'm sure you love berkeley berkeley i
love berkeley um but how do we get more
people to care about these problems how
do we get more people at places like
yale to be actually thinking about this
problem you get when people are building
bridges you know no one's like oh
there's that there's that one lab over
over there thinking about how to make
sure the bridge doesn't collapse
but that's not the case in a.i uh so how
do we actually sort of get more people
to be researching this
i would say for my part um
i think
growing the field is very much one of
the ambitions that i had with the book
so as i said one of the ambitions was to
help non-technical people feel like they
can become you know sort of have a
working fluency in machine learning and
the other
of my main goals was to bring more
people into the fold
so i'm encouraged that you know you're
you're motivated and i think partly um
students can exert
gentle pressure on their professors and
say like hey i would really love to do
some kind of summer project or research
project in this direction is there
anything cool that you know about that i
could work on so that's a way that sort
of from the bottom up i think
you can help just sort of grow the mind
share in this area
i mean i'm i'm impressed that you took
matters into your own hands i also think
um you know there might be there might
be some collaborations
across department that are not
um
not immediately obvious but you might
find some kindred spirits in neighboring
departments so you know we we were
talking earlier
one of my closest friends and closest
collaborators tom griffiths i met when i
was a computer science undergrad i was
really frustrated because i didn't feel
like anything that was happening in the
cs department reflected my desire to
learn more about human cognition
and i bumped into this guy from the
cognitive science department that said
well yeah i basically used the tools of
computer science to think about people
and i was like oh there's the guy he was
just in the other department
um so that might also be possible
sure
thanks again thanks for this talk this
was super interesting um
i also have have been
speak up a little more i've also been
really interested in this alignment
problem i actually think i'm going to be
working on it
next year like for part-time research
doing doing this kind of thing
particularly i wanted to ask like with
respect to what you were just talking
about with cognitive science
what where do you see because obviously
this seems like kind of the center of
the bullseye of this is a cs problem of
some sort
where do you think the most productive
ways neuroscientists psychologists
cognitive scientists and general
philosophers can interface with this
problem in a way that like where the
areas where this is the most neglected
and where you think the most work needs
to be done from that kind of top-down
perspective
yeah
really cool question so
um ways that cognitive science
intersects here i mentioned temporal
difference learning and dopamine that's
that's like one of the seminal things
but there's still work to be done uh
there in neuroscience that continues to
this day
um
i talked a little bit about
reward shaping so there's this idea uh
from andrew eng and stuart russell uh
it's called policy invariance under
reward transformations it's like what
are the difference types of incentives
that you can use
that don't result in a different final
policy of your agent and that's really
useful i think not just in computer
science that's useful in thinking about
like
management or economics right um that
the term alignment problem is borrowed
from the economics literature um and so
it's interesting there are cognitive
scientists like falk leader at max plunk
in europe who is using this idea of
reward shaping and policy invariants to
think about
optimal gamification strategies
so how you can break it down a task and
assign points to each subtask such that
you can incentivize the person to like
not procrastinate um very cool and that
draws directly on the computer science
of reward shaping
um i mentioned montezuma's revenge which
is a game that's very stingy with
rewards it turns out a lot of the
progress there has been done through
what's called intrinsic motivation
how can we make an agent that's
motivated internally rather than by
external points from the environment but
by its own sense of like exploration and
play and novelty seeking
and that was a case where computer
scientists like mark belmar at deepmind
and mila um
teapot pathak who's at
cmu
they turned to like developmental
psychologists people who study like
infant cognition people like alison
gopnik laura schultz at mit
uh and said like what do you what do you
have for us in terms of like formal
models of like novelty-seeking behavior
or self-surprise that we can plug into
our montezuma's revenge thing and they
plugged in this uh
you know they sort of translated it into
reinforcement learning terms and plugged
this like novelty drive into the agent
and then suddenly it beats the game
because it's playing the game the reason
a human would which is to just like see
what's on the other side of the door
and that turns out to be a more powerful
driver than just looking for external
rewards even if all you're measuring it
by is its ability to achieve external
rewards so that sort of work uh has a
lot of connection to developmental
cognition very cool and then lastly
um
this reward modeling work or
the field of what's called inverse
reinforcement learning you're observing
an agent making decisions and you have
to infer the reward that they're
optimizing well there's kind of a huge
problem here which is that
we we know pretty well that humans are
not like
perfect reward maximizers
and so i think there's a lot of really
cool
neuroscience cognitive science
psychology economics behavioral
economics work to be done
giving a better theoretical framework to
the inverse reinforcement learning
community about how to work backwards
from
how a person
how you observe a person behaving and
what inferences you're kind of allowed
to make
about what you think their values are i
think that's a huge open question and
like there's so many fields that really
touch that
let me just add a little bit to that um
so you know for for many years you know
decades
machine learning
advanced by just sort of crude
abstractions for how the mind might work
you know like the feed forward neural
network
and things progressed quite remarkably
far just given those types of
abstractions but now it's progressed to
the point
where
you know we can take
more clues from human cognition to
inform
artificial systems as brian was talking
about but we're also at the point where
we can turn it in the other direction
and we can develop models
for learning
that can be used as kind of a
computational laboratory for informing
our understanding for how the brain
works and this is something where you
know
that's very much of interest to the
wussai institute um so i think we're at
this uh you know kind of turning point
where it becomes mutually profitable to
to study um artificial intelligence and
human intelligence simultaneously
hi i'm talia i'm a physics grad student
um
my question is i wanted to pick up on
the point you raised about
the kind of analogy to nutritional
labeling
being clear about how an algorithm was
trained or
what its objective function is
so i wonder about what you see as the
future of that how it could be built on
or expanded in particular i'm imagining
like you mentioned what the goal was of
tinder and facebook how they measured
success and i imagine a user might have
a different experience if that were
labeled really big at the top of you
know facebook when you're on there
what's the goal we're trying to get out
of you now they might not want to do
that but
i wonder what you think might be the
future for
a legislation in that regard or other
means of incentivizing more transparency
about
what what is the machine learning
algorithms goal that you are interfacing
with yeah i love this question so i
think this is a huge area for some kind
of regulation
down the line i don't know exactly what
it would be but i'm completely
of of a mind with what you're saying
that we need something like that
it's interesting to think about the
failures of policy to
you know provide meaningful consent
right if you go to any european website
there's just like a cookie pop-up that
you're like okay sure um
and so
that's
an example of it sort of disclosure done
wrong in a way that you just create sort
of like consent fatigue
without any actual insight
it's interesting to me i mean sites like
reddit
it's
this is not like the most impressive
thing in the world but reddit gives you
four different metrics by which to sort
the replies you can sort by new you can
sort by best you can sort by
controversial
and
i think that is both there's both an
aspect of transparency there and also an
aspect of
agency um
and we're increasingly seeing
uh you know instagram and others
relenting and saying okay if you really
want reverse kron you can have it
um twitter twitter does the same thing
now
i think
providing meaningful oversight or
meaningful transparency in that way with
something i would really like to see
is a system where you could let's say on
twitter you could articulate your goals
as a user you're like i want to learn
more about machine learning i want to
learn more about public policy i want to
look at my friends cute pets or whatever
and you can have some range of goals and
then for everything that appears in your
timeline
it's incumbent to twitter to tell you
which of your goals it thinks that piece
of content will serve
and you can maybe have some feedback
mechanism where you say no that's not an
example of a cute pet or whatever that's
not informing me about ai but that sort
of puts you in the driver's seat um and
then it becomes up to them to make the
case for how they're achieving your
goals
um something like that i think it's
quite within the realm of like 2022
machine learning um and will become
increasingly possible to just verbally
articulate what you want to do and have
it sort of get the get the gist
um in the
i want to say one last thing about
the criminal justice space so
we've been talking about these huge
reward models uh language models that
have like trillions of parameters etc
a lot of what i think is some of the
most exciting work happening in machine
learning is not happening with large
models but it's happening with like
exhaustive search over all possible
simple models
so there's a computer scientist at duke
named cynthia rudin who has done work on
both in the medical context and in the
criminal justice context
on
creating optimal simple models that are
competitive accuracy-wise with neural
networks
and come with a sort of certificate of
optimality that says of all simple
models we can prove that this is the
best one
um and for example she has a model which
i can probably tell you the entire thing
off the top my head it's
if you are
under 20 and male predict that you'll be
rearrest and you're arrested predict
that you'll be re-arrested within two
years or if you're under 23 and you have
two priors or
more or if you have three priors or more
predict rearrests within two years
otherwise predict you will not be
rearrested within two years that is the
entire model i've just told you the
entire thing and that is competitive for
accuracy against compass which is this
proprietary closed source thing that
costs however much money and no one
knows what is really in it and people
write papers trying to reverse engineer
it because it's such a big deal
in some ways i think
it is now
like inexcusable
for a government
to use a proprietary tool
when they could use something that fits
into a single english sentence because
effectively
these models in my view become
extensions of the law right if this is
determining or at the very least
informing whether you are released when
you're arrested or not pending trial so
you haven't been tried yet
um that is in my view an extension of
the law there's the famous lawrence
lesson code as law
well i think we should demand that the
law be
on the books and legible to the people
that are beholden to the law and so to
the degree that machine learning models
are
the law
then we should demand that they're both
legible and
and publicly available so i i would
support legislation for example that
mandated the use of uh models of like
that in those situations
so i think sadly we've reached the end
of our time but please join me in
thanking uh ryan and also john for
moderating
[Applause]
[Music]
you